[Aplausos]
[Música]
terremotos los terremotos son uno de los
fenómenos naturales que más impacto han
causado a lo largo de toda la historia
de la humanidad
[Música]
ah
han destruido ciudades enteras y han
cegado la vida de millones y millones de
personas eso no es nada nuevo lo que sí
es más nuevo es saber cómo resistir los
cómo sobrevivir y cómo hacer cada vez
más seguros los edificios y las
infraestructuras
eso eso amigos sí que es un fenómeno muy
actual pero en toda esta cuestión hay
dos países que por necesidad por
desgracia sabe mucho amigos chile y
japón son los dos países más
sísmicamente activos del planeta
[Música]
cada uno de ellos concentra en torno al
20 por ciento de todos los movimientos
sísmicos que se producen en el mundo de
hecho chile es el país que ha sufrido el
terremoto más potente jamás registrado
el terremoto de valdivia en 1960 tuvo
una magnitud de 9 5 en la escala de
richter un verdadero cataclismo
japón y chile están enclavados en pleno
cinturón de fuego una franja de 40.000
km que constituye la región de la tierra
con más actividad sísmica y volcánica en
esta zona en las placas tectónicas
subduce es decir una se introduce por
debajo de la otra generando zonas de
subducción ese movimiento no es
constante en irregular sino que sucede a
tirones y cuando ambas placas están muy
tensas y con mucha energía acumulada
entonces ceden se sueltan y se mueven de
golpe generando fuertes terremotos este
es el motivo por el que en el cinturón
de fuego se producen ni más ni menos que
el 90 el 90 por ciento de todos los
terremotos en el mundo y el 80 por
ciento de los más potentes los mega
terremotos y de hecho los terremotos de
japón y chile son muy pero que muy
similares en magnitud y duración
podéis imaginar que con semejante reto
hay que elegir adaptarse o pasarlo muy
pero que muy mal hoy en visual político
os contamos cómo lo han hecho cuáles son
las principales diferencias entre ambos
y el gran reto común al que se enfrentan
japón y chile atentos
ah
chili japón aprender a base de golpes
amigos amigas los terremotos más
destructivos tienen consecuencias
terribles hablamos de fenómenos que
pueden acabar con la vida de decenas y
decenas de miles de personas en apenas
unos pocos minutos en todo 8 muertos 541
en el maule 64 en bío bío y 103 en otras
regiones y hay un número todavía yo
diría creciente de personas
desaparecidas si él y japón son los
países más avanzados en prevención de
desastres sísmicos por una sencilla
razón a lo largo de su historia han
vivido terribles tragedias que les han
enseñado una lección muy valiosa merece
la pena gastar más al principio para
ahorrar costes humanos y de
reconstrucción para requerir que
trabajemos juntos como hijo de una misma
patria detrás de esa gran causa
reconstruir nuestro país que va a estar
en el programa levantemos chile' pero
para ver más claro la magnitud de todo
lo que estamos hablando pongamos un
ejemplo todavía está en la retina de
todos
el 11 de marzo del año 2011 es una de
esas fechas que seguro todos podemos
recordar ese día un enorme terremoto de
magnitud 9,1 se originó en la prefectura
de miyagi en japón pero sacudió buena
parte del país incluida la capital tokio
el gran terremoto del este y el
posterior tsunami dejaron a sus espaldas
casi 16.000 fallecidos y más de 6000
heridos y si estamos hablando del
terremoto que terminó causando el
desastre de fukushima
este ha sido el último mega terremoto en
japón pero amigos los japoneses saben
que hay un 70 por ciento de
posibilidades de que un mega terremoto
suceda en tokio durante los próximos 30
años
[Música]
y si vale es verdad que la gran mayoría
más del 85% de los edificios de tokio se
consideran resistentes pero el hecho de
que haya 16.000 hectáreas cubiertas por
edificios de madera en la capital
japonesa no ayuda según algunas
simulaciones los escapes de gas
producidos por un gran terremoto podrían
causar incendios por toda la ciudad y
destruir más de 600.000 edificios las
consecuencias van mucho más allá de los
temblores y los posibles derrumbes y
claro todo esto es algo que genera
conciencia social y política en chile
por su parte van algo por detrás pero el
shock social del 2010 hizo que se tomase
aún más en serio la prevención de
riesgos y por ello será necesario
reajustar el programa de gobierno y
ahora seguirá recorriendo estudiante al
que guano y concepción de su regreso
emplazó directamente al gobierno por el
desorden y los saqueos en el
supermercado un terremoto de 8,8 grados
de magnitud sacude chile el terremoto de
un minuto de duración pudo sentirse en
la capital donde se interrumpió el
servicio eléctrico
el maremoto causado por el seísmo llega
a hawai el terremoto de chile fue
horrible pero pudo haber sido mucho peor
chile es uno de los países más ricos y
mejor organizados de sudamérica y muchos
de sus hogares y oficinas fueron
construidos para ser resistentes a los
terremotos amigos el terremoto de chile
afectó al 70% de la población del país
pero gracias a las regulaciones
antisísmicas por ejemplo tan solo dos
construcciones en altura se desplomaron
en la capital santiago y eso ante un
terremoto así es en cierto modo todo un
éxito especialmente teniendo en cuenta
los precedentes en una región como
latinoamerica las inversiones de chile
en infraestructura resiliente sistemas
de alerta temprana y planificación
urbana han logrado asegurar que en esta
ocasión el número de víctimas sea bajo a
pesar de la intensidad del terremoto
margareta wahlström ex representante
especial de la oficina de las naciones
unidas para la reducción del riesgo de
desastres
[Música]
y esto es en lo que hay que incidir ya
lo dice el proverbio mejor prevenir que
curar pero cómo han conseguido japón y
chile lograr estos niveles de prevención
de riesgos existen diferencias entre
ambos modelos cuáles son las debilidades
las claves para salvar vidas
[Música]
si hay riesgo adelántate a él
cuando hablamos de terremotos debemos
tener clarísimas dos cosas son
impredecibles e inevitables sin embargo
lo que sí se puede predecir y evitar son
los riesgos derivados de los terremotos
veréis ante un terremoto la prevención
puede ser de dos tipos activa y pasiva
por ejemplo tras el terremoto de
valdivia del año 1960 el más fuerte
jamás registrado y que causó un tsunami
enorme se creó cinco años más tarde el
sistema de advertencia y mitigación del
pacífico' por parte de la comisión
oceanográfica intergubernamental de la
unesco con el objetivo precisamente de
difundir alertas tempranas de tsunami
[Música]
tranquilos no os asustéis porque sea tan
antiguo el sistema se ha ido
actualizando con el paso del tiempo el
caso es que ese es uno de los mejores
ejemplos de prevención activa
[Música]
un tsunami en el pacífico tiene una
enorme capacidad de propagación y pueden
llegar a ser muy pero que muy
destructivos normalmente pasan unos 20 o
30 minutos desde que se produce el
terremoto hasta que el tsunami golpea la
costa más cercana pero en el caso del
terremoto de japón del año 2011 en
algunas zonas tan solo pasaron dos
minutos entre la alerta y el tsunami
claro tratándose de fenómenos que
requieren de evacuaciones masivas y que
afectan a regiones inmensas las alertas
tempranas son sumamente importantes muy
importantes cuanto más tiempo haya mejor
que mejor cada segundo cuenta
[Música]
de hecho un terremoto fuerte originado
en chile puede provocar un tsunami tan
grande que afecte a costas muy alejadas
como las japonesas neozelandesas
estadounidenses e incluso filipinas
[Música]
el caso amigos es que precisamente por
eso japón también cuenta con su propio
sistema de alerta temprana muy mejorado
por cierto tras la catástrofe del 2011
[Música]
desde ese año se han invertido más de 25
mil millones de dólares
en sensores sísmicos terrestres para
llegar a los 280 la red más densa y
fiable del mundo
sin embargo el mayor reto con mucha
diferencia es la prevención pasiva es
decir todas esas medidas y normas que
buscan minimizar los daños en las
construcciones y por tanto minimizar las
víctimas y en esto japón es el líder
indiscutible el estricto código de
construcción de japón salva vidas pero
en qué consiste exactamente fijaos a
pesar de que la primera normativa
antisísmica para la construcción en
japon data del año 1924 en la actualidad
la mayor parte de los edificios están
construidos bajo dos normativas muy
diferentes la antigua la llamada kaixin
data de 1950 y se centraba en evitar el
derrumbe de los edificios la nueva o sin
tie zinc del año 1981 en cambio exige
que en los terremotos de medios a
fuertes el edificio como mucho presente
algunas grietas pero que pueda seguir
utilizándose ese es el requisito
estas normas evidentemente se han ido
reforzando parcialmente con el paso de
los años es por esto que las estructuras
de los edificios en japón son
mayoritariamente de acero mucho más
flexible y resistente a los movimientos
en lugar del rígido hormigón además en
algunos casos también se instalan vigas
transversales que absorben energía del
terremoto y por supuesto cuentan también
con amortiguadores sísmicos en la base
de los edificios más altos
chile por el contrario no exige que los
edificios no sufran daños sino que la
normativa se orienta más a que no se
vengan abajo su normativa actual se
parece un poco más a la japonesa de 1950
con esto podéis daros cuenta de la
enorme diferencia de visión que tienen
en chile donde la regulación es mucho
menos estricta es decir en chile se
busca salvar vidas pero sin que sea
necesario que los edificios queden
indemne si esto tiene una explicación
fundamental el coste construir un
edificio tan resistente como los de
japón puede costar en torno a un 10 o un
15% más que uno más común menos
preparado y claro eso hace que los
precios de las viviendas en edificios
más nuevos y resistentes sean más caros
la filosofía eso sí es si vives aquí
estarás seguro
pero esperad un momento estamos dando
por hecho que las normas siempre se
cumplen que todo es bonito y sencillo
cuando la realidad puede ser muy
diferente
de hecho sabéis cuál es el principal
problema que afecta a la seguridad y
puede costar muchas vidas pensando un
momento
exacto habéis acertado
[Música]
i
atención la corrupción mata
si habéis escuchado bien no es que la
corrupción ya sea mala sino que es que
mata
puede que te sorprenda pero la
corrupción es sin lugar a dudas la mayor
amenaza para la seguridad en caso de
terremotos y no nos crea es que japón y
chile están libres de esta lacra porque
aunque japón tenga esa imagen idílica de
país y chile esté en un decente puesto
27 en el índice de percepción de la
corrupción de vez en cuando saltan
escándalos como este atentos a finales
de 2018 la kawaii be corporation una
empresa japonesa dedicada al desarrollo
y fabricación de amortiguadores sísmicos
reconoció haber falseado durante más de
una década en los datos de calidad y
rendimiento de sus productos a día de
hoy todavía no se ha podido cuantificar
el alcance real del riesgo que esto
supone pero se estima que la efectividad
de los productos falseados podría rondar
el 86 por ciento de los requisitos
mínimos que exige la ley edificios tan
importantes como el ayuntamiento de
tokio el centro acuático olímpico y el
área que arena la sede de los juegos
olímpicos de 2020 utilizan
amortiguadores sísmicos de esta empresa
[Música]
y por si esto fuera poco la torre más
alta del mundo también la toques que
instruye entre los edificios
relacionados con el escándalo de datos
del fabricante de amortiguadores
sísmicos que igual vi corporation eso sí
aunque como veis este caso es muy grave
lo cierto es que japón es un país poco
corrupto y eso hace que las regulaciones
antisísmicas se cumplan la inmensa
mayoría de las veces
por su parte chile tiene el menor nivel
de corrupción de toda latinoamérica lo
que ha contribuido a que las normativas
antisísmicas en la construcción se
cumplan en la inmensa mayor parte de los
casos aunque eso sí como ya hemos visto
son menos mucho menos exigentes que las
de japón
tenemos una ley que señala que los
diseños de cierta altura tienen que ser
revisados por un equipo independiente
que verifica que se esté cumpliendo con
la normativa nadie construye sino un
respaldo de este tipo sergio sepúlveda
académico de geología de la universidad
de chile pero sabes que es precisamente
este amplio cumplimiento de las reglas
lo que hace que chile sea un país
muchísimo más seguro que por ejemplo
méxico para revivir un terremoto
corrupción y negligencia que usaron
derrumbes en el sismo de ciudad de
mexico
seguro que todos o la inmensa mayoría de
los que nos veis desde méjico habéis
vivido uno o varios terremotos
la diferencia con chile es que en la
ciudad de mexico cada vez que se produce
un terremoto fuerte varios edificios se
derrumban dejando numerosas víctimas y
aunque es cierto que no todos los
terremotos tienen las mismas
características por ejemplo por el tipo
de suelo y la profundidad en el
terremoto del 19 de septiembre del año
2017 perdieron la vida tan solo en la
capital ciudad de mexico 228 personas y
fueron 369 los fallecidos en todo el
país en cambio en chile el terremoto del
año 2015 en coquimbo que se situó con
intensidad 7 en santiago tan solo causó
15 víctimas mortales en todo el país
todo un ejemplo de preparación
antisísmica por esto amigos méxico y
otros países altamente sísmicos deben
ponerse las pilas y trabajar dura y
honestamente por la seguridad de sus
ciudadanos
'no toma nota
y ahora os paso la pelota que creéis qué
pasaría si sucediera un terremoto fuerte
en vuestro país creéis que hay
separación en las construcciones y
planes de evacuación que salven vidas y
a nuestros amigos mexicanos como creéis
que se puede acabar con la corrupción
que afecta la seguridad antisísmica como
siempre dejar vuestro comentario aquí
abajo y no os olvidéis de darle al botón
de like i suscribiros al canal para
estar a la última de todo el contenido
de visual político un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]